I think earlier I called you all soul
sisters as you introduced me well
because you came out behind earn so I
would enjoy so she's like Lapidus
sidekick that I you guys I mean you
didn't meet during eclipse you've known
each other for like 10 10 years plus
right yeah run across each other we both
training just in the industry well the
the the world of theater and acting is
small when it comes to like Africans
especially ten years ago and I'd heard
of Dan I had seen she was in the movie
the visitor and I'd heard of her play in
the continuum that she'd done out of the
NYU program and had gone to do other
things and she won an Obie and I
happened to be at the Opie's with my
best friend and he very boldly said you
have to meet deny and he came and he
didn't even know deny he introduced me
to her and then we struck up for
conversation and stuff and I was a real
big admirer of her I mean she was doing
things that I wanted to do and and stuff
like that and so we got talking and she
yeah we got talking and then next thing
I know in 2009 I get accepted to the
Yale School of Drama and the very school
fighting over her and so Tish calls the
African lumps and says get on this get
her here
yes and we were like me and yam B and a
few others like we're on it was that you
know that we knew the teacher you wanted
and he admitted and why you value yeah
yeah like oh we can't I can't argue that
he that's a teacher I was right there
yeah I went to you but I learned under
the teacher who were taught her Rondon
loose so you know in the end it was when
I got to Yale the very first play that I
got to understudy was her production of
eclipsed and so I was in that rehearsal
room and everything and I made a promise
to myself that one day I would get to
play that character and then it was my
Broadway debut I saw it on Broadway and
it was fantastic I mean it yeah it's
kind of snatched me right here
especially you I mean oh I can't we
could talk about that all day we have we
have to talk about this okay so but how
did both of you guys get involved in
black panther because i read that you
said yes and you had any read script you
ain't care well I care they didn't have
a script to show me and they wouldn't
have a script for a while so I guess we
both had to sign up before we see the
script yeah I mean I I just I was
actually at the opening night of eclipse
to wear um it was it was on Broadway it
was a Mart in March of 2016 and I was
coming out of the whatever that was big
building party and my manager says I
have an offer here for
[Music]
[Laughter]
so that was catching up with what that
was all about over the next week or so
and then and I was I was like okay okay
okay and then I heard it was Ryan and I
was like oh my gosh cuz I loved him so
much from the work he done I was just
like so proud of him like I had this
pride about him I'd never met him in my
life but I was just so proud of him and
what he'd done how he he told stories
that needed to be told and was so young
and just right out of grad school just
did that and and I was just like wow I
already really admire this man so I met
him here in LA about a month later and
when I heard his vision and you know it
is it is something like you know I think
we're both quite picky about African
stories and how they're gonna be handled
you know it's you know they've been
they've been mangled many a time let's
just be honest so it was very important
to to hear the vision and his vision was
really really fantastic so ya know I
hadn't I hadn't read it but I was on
yeah after that conversation and III had
signed on to it I wanted a few months
before that moment and we didn't know we
were why we were working on Eclipse
we didn't know that we were both in it
cuz you know it's all top secrecy right
until Ryan came to see eclipsed right
and then he said yo your girl she's it I
think maybe through your maybe through
your manager or something at old mine or
something like that okay like I didn't
know can we talk training for a second
because no lie I was in the gym this
morning like I'm trying to get like
these ladies I'm trying to say him what
I need to know everything you did
everything you ate every bit of it cuz I
want to do it cuz you guys look oh yeah
I mean it was it was it was dead
vacation you know we least we had a boot
camp for like six weeks before the
filming started where we just focused on
all the physical needs for the
characters it started off as at four
hours a day for me for like two weeks
and then I was like walking up and they
had to take it to two hours a day and it
involved us doing like a group warm-up
where all of us did it together
it was quite job it was not easy I mean
it was the dorm Ellijay chadwick Michael
Winston who else was at latisha and we
all did the warm-ups together and then
we branch off and do our individual
styles of fighting and figure out those
stunts and stuff like that this is the
best natural fighter of you guys when
you're a trained indeed who do you wanna
be when stuff goes dad has like history
in in martial arts like and he's just
smooth with it yeah understands the
thing about he's in with it
he's totally Zen the thing about
fighting is that it takes like a mental
stability and a mental acumen you know
that doesn't necessarily come naturally
and is this a philosophy of a battle of
combat you know and Chadwick has it and
he understands the anatomy as well so
like he can just like flip your wrist
and and you're incapacitated and he has
a cuz he's done it forever so I was
always just in awe that I kiss his
ability to like speak the language of
battle mm-hmm but he she said you that
you were the most natural fighter she
saw you know checks in the mail but I
mean I guess each is owed you know but I
mean it was very much like you know it
was um you know we had some amazing
women in there as well like there were
women who I loved the the women they got
us for we got to go get together with
for the Dorma logic these women are some
of them are stunt women
some of them are from dance some of them
were from things like you know even
circus performance like it was a very
interesting group of women who came
together from all over the world and who
all brought in great like Grace and
ability and and and all of that so you
know and you know I I was interesting
for me I guess the difference between
this character and and Michonne was just
you know in the walking dead it was just
that this character there's there's a
history to how the Dermalogica
which is you know there's a tradition a
Koya is totally a traditionalist and so
you know she really is about form and
and specificity of and she's gonna keep
that form even when she's you know with
dealing with a bunch of baddies and in
Korea you know she's gonna retain her
ancient form of how you you come back
because there's nothing better than you
know like this is how the wakandans do
it and this is the best way it's done
okay I know
one last question I know you are we saw
you in the trailer of for infinity war
so what was what's it like the
difference being on that set then this
well it was you know there was it was a
lot more people a lot it was a different
world of people you know what I mean
which was really interesting to
reconnect with these people that you've
you know it's very interesting coming on
set and they like you know there's this
whole other world of people you've seen
on the big screen a lot and now you're
like about to work with them and that
was a that was pretty awesome
that was pretty cool but it was it was
just the world expanded which I guess is
why it's called the Marvel Universe it
like you felt like absolutely oh this is
the universe like I felt that universe
the minute I walked on that set I think
this is gonna be a good opening because
don't you have a birthday a couple days
before aren't you a Valentine baby well
then that week that's already blessed
because it'll be the nice birthday and
the movie will open so there we go
the Peters planning parties I'm never
coming to America Marty
and I'm gonna top that yeah